we're officially in the last season of
the year 2020 has been a year full of
unexpected twists
mostly of the bad kind unfortunately but
hey japan's well on the road to recovery
and we now have
2021 to look forward to now i pray that
i don't jinx it the way i did 2020 with
my preview last year but screw it let me
just say it 2021
looks an amazing year as early as now
and we're still not over the finale of
attack on titan which will start this
december
not quite the 2021 hit that i expected
when the listings got taken down a few
weeks back by the way before everything
i'd like you to hit that thumbs up and
subscribe to this channel and my other
one which i'll be linking above hit that
subscribe button to bless our
2021 because we've got a load of hype
blockbusters coming up the multiple
finales of the past season are just the
start apparently i don't want to keep
you waiting anymore so let's get the
show going with our top 10 most
anticipated anime shows of 2021 we have
a lot of classics making their comebacks
so let's get the ball rolling with
shaman king
[Music]
i bet a lot of you young ones are
excited for this after almost two
decades we'll be seeing the return of
shaman king one of the most beloved
classic shonen at the start of the
millennium for those who aren't caught
up
shaman king is the story of the shaman
fight a large-scale tournament hitting
shamans and their spirits against each
other the goal
obtain the great spirit and get the
power to reshape the world at will now
the series revolves around the carefree
yo
asakura who gets thrust into the shaman
fight discovering new allies and foes as
he discovers more about the world of
spirits and the secrets behind the whole
tournament the shaman king anime of the
2000s deviated from the manga pretty
early with only the first few arcs
getting an accurate adaptation from the
manga a lot of fans were left
disappointed that's no surprise but it's
time to rejoice for those of you who
stuck around for so long
this new edition of shaman king is
rebooting the storyline
and following the manga so you finally
get to see all the craziness that
happens in the manga in anime form for
those who haven't read it trust me
things get really crazy later on
rising of the shield hero makes its
glorious return this 2021 and it's up
next on our list
says
it's finally here i'm not gonna lie i
actually thought they forgot about the
second season of shield hero altogether
after being announced some time ago news
of the second season has been
non-existent
until now the second season of the
rising of the shield hero has finally
been announced for next year with a new
rocking trailer the first season ended
in quite an awkward spot for me while i
thank the anime team for not ending it
on such a steep cliffhanger it still
ended with the adventure far from
finished and given how much i enjoyed
the series i just couldn't wait for more
anime what about the upcoming waves
what would happen to the status quo now
that we know the existence of another
world that has its own heroes with goals
opposing our heroes if the anime sticks
to the source material we should be
seeing the intermission arc and spirit
turtle arc expect to also see more of
not only the other three heroes but also
the arc and the rest of the heroes from
another world anyone else ready to see
now fool me back in action
let's go
up next is the last one among the
rebuild of evangelion movies
yes the wait is finally over almost a
decade after the latest film
the film rebuild of evangelion movie is
set to be released in january 2021
after having some test screenings of the
first few minutes in 2019
we finally got a trailer and it looks
every bit of awesome
i don't think that i need to explain why
this movie belongs here just look at
your social media erupting joy after the
trailer recently dropped with over two
hours of action
we'll get to see what promises to be an
entirely new alternative end to the
series i wonder how they can top what we
currently have
which is end of evangelion the wait will
surely be worth it for all of us if
you're one of the people who just can't
get enough of one of the landmark mecca
titles in anime history
2021 is gonna be an awesome year
for those praying for the slow decline
of the isakai genre i've got some real
bad news for you on the bright side
2021 a isakai titles are looking very
promising the ones that have been
announced so far have been greenlit with
much fanfare and one of the front
runners of 2020's isakai is mushoko
tensei the isakai device of choice is
putting in a lot of work once again
ramming down our 34 year old protagonist
and sending him into the body of rudius
greyrat however as always in these
stories he retains the knowledge from
his previous rank filling him with the
desire to start over and not repeat the
mistakes of his past
in his second life however with all the
gifts that he retained from his past
life he also comes into this world with
his other trait as a human on earth
being a perverted otaku who dreams of
making moves on women i know the
synopsis might not seem too special
given what we typically have for isakai
but
mushoko tensei is one of the more
popular titles out there and for a good
reason it has good character progression
great themes on redemption and coming of
age and has one of the most profoundly
built worlds in isekai i wonder how
these will translate into the anime
adaptation or how the show as a whole
will hold up but that's the fun of
waiting for adaptations right
[Music]
next up is my hero academia's fifth
season for shonen jump
my hero academia is the gift that just
keeps giving am i really supposed to be
surprised that we're going to be getting
a fifth season of this on another note i
like how my hero academia takes breaks
and adapts the arcs in chunks to keep
anticipation up and avoid the shonen
trap of filler health this time we'll be
going to the continuation of the pro
hero arc and the battle against the nomu
the previous season has been one
big redemption after endeavour and for
the next arc we should cover the
training arc that pits class
1a and 1b against each other all the way
to the start of the endeavor agency arc
you'll also be seeing the villains take
the spotlight in one of the more unique
shonen arcs out there who's excited for
my hero academia 5.
i sure am spring 2021 just can't come
fast enough
following that is to your eternity
if things were normal to your eternity
would have premiered this year but as we
all know
2020 is definitely not a normal year and
the much anticipated series has been
pushed back
2021 it is them i've already talked
about the synopsis in length in the
previous seasonal preview videos that i
made from the creator of the critically
acclaimed a silent voice comes this
brand new story about an immortal being
that finds itself on earth having
experienced the source material i'll
vouch for it as one of the more
thought-provoking and dramatic series
that we do have coming up next year it
may be premature since we're still a
quarter away from 2021 but given the
quality of the source material and the
staff behind the anime team i'm sure
that this one is not going to disappoint
seeing the dramatic tale of an alien
organism learning about the qualities
that make our world what it is might
have to wait but the wait
will be worth it
coming in next is dr stone's second
season
it's been announced for quite some time
but we finally got our release date one
of the amazing 2019 series out there dr
stone has managed to blend the fantastic
with the realistic in a mix that you
don't really see in a lot of anime
weaving together some unexpectedly
educational content with the fantasies
and the adventure-filled charm of anime
it came as no surprise that dr stone has
become a fan favorite of course we all
can't wait to see more so we'll be
getting more dr stone coming up with the
title saying stone wars we can expect
the continuation of the titular
arc however i doubt that the fun ends
there i'm quite certain that we'll be
getting some sort of the age of
exploration arc and some major headway
in getting the truth behind the
petrification that completely changed
the world
dr stone stone wars comes to our screens
this january
that's a lot of action and fantasy we
have lined up so how about something
fluffier and more romantic for our next
entry
[Music]
just a short while ago i record my news
feed erupting in joy at this
announcement at long last horimia is set
to get an anime adaptation so horimia is
about two people who have hidden sights
to each other
school idol not that definition of idol
mind you kyoko hard is one who has
little chance to socialize away from
school a complete busy body she has no
time for lots of the joys of teenage
years on the flip side you have izumi
miyamoura a brooding otaku who actually
has a gentle side behind him
also he's quite littered with piercings
and tattoos stuff you wouldn't associate
with geeky goody two-shoes types what
happens when their parts cross in a
chance meeting outside school having
read some of the source material i'd say
that the series is full of surprises it
may seem to have a rom-com premise with
a simple twist but i definitely had a
lot of fun with it it's a lot better
than you'd expect and it just
ended up being a really pleasant
surprise it's such a soothing and
wholesome story that would melt your
hearts this winter 20210
it's been a long journey for gintama and
as they say every journey has a
conclusion luckily for gintama's loyal
fan base that's been following the epic
story for so many years we'll be getting
the last chapters of the manga
adaptation in the form of a full-length
movie
talk about ending with a bang her after
the dust settled from the final battle
against utsoro peace and everyday
hijinks returned for gentoki and the
gang now that the ultimate enemy has
already been defeated
what awaits kintoki and the rest of the
eurozouya turns out that we get one last
adventure to go through before bidding
the rest of the gang farewell
of course they can't afford to give a
less than excellent product
given the status of gintama topping the
list for me is the second
season of the promised neverland
[Music]
i didn't expect myself to be so excited
for a sequel to a series that i felt
ended on a pretty good note
still life awaits the children after
their escape from gracefield and we
reunite with them as they try to survive
the world outside
uncertainty and danger loom in every
corner and it will take everything that
emma
ray and the rest of the kids have in
order to live after all they've just
gone out of the frying pan and into the
fire
with a whole society of demons
presumably lying in weight in the world
beyond the promised neverland has become
one of the big hits of modern shonen and
anticipation for the continuation of it
is at an all-time high
what awaits the grace field escapees in
the society of demons
let's all tune in to find out
among the 10 titles which are you the
most excited about for 2020. i think
that we've got a very loaded year and
i'm very much excited for more shield
hero and my hero academia
horimia looks to be my comfy show of
choice too what about you let me hear
your thoughts on the comments below so
that i can get to know you better keep
in mind i didn't include series like
bleach and made in abyss season 2
because they haven't been confirmed to
air during 2020. before you leave make
sure to smash that thumbs up and
subscribe it would really help this
channel grow and nothing makes me
happier than being able to share my
thoughts on anime with you
or some fans that's it for this edition
of vini tube list and i'll see you on
the next one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you